police in Missouri believe a man stabbed
to death on a busy highway may have been
a victim of road rage 23 year old Cody
harder was a member of the Missouri Air
National Guard he was found dead near
his vehicle in Lee's Summit Saturday
night Michelle Miller is here with the
family's search for answers Michelle
good morning good morning witnesses told
police Cody harder and another man were
in traffic when they got into an
argument Saturday police say they hope
surveillance video will help them find
the suspect
but for now Harder's family is begging
anyone with information about what
happened to him
to come forward at a press conference
Sunday Cody harder sister Kylie called
on his killer to turn himself in harder
who served a tour in Iraq was killed on
a highway in Missouri Saturday he did
not deserve Carter was found dead near
his vehicle Saturday night and what
police described as a possible road rage
incident witnesses told police they saw
harder and another man arguing on the
shoulder near where highway 291 merges
into interstate 470 they believe the
argument escalated and harder was
stabbed he stumbled and then collapsed
into traffic the suspect fled in a
vehicle going north on i-4 70 hearts
family said he owned a lawn care
business and had been driving home after
picking up a new mower in Kansas City
police released a photo of Harder's
truck a maroon 2003 Chevrolet Silverado
they're asking anyone who may have
passed by his vehicle Saturday night to
call police police are trying to put
together a description of the suspects
vehicle but said they need more
witnesses to step forward with
information Carter's mother said he was
attending classes at a local university
and only had one semester left until he
graduated with an engineering technology
degree he also leaves behind a
girlfriend he had planned to marry soon
just heartbreaking
such a tragedy unbelievable Michelle
thank you